all right Scott
yeah weight from originally where'd you
grow one in California
Joey and tell me about your family her
both your parents yeah both my parents
are the divorced when I was young my dad
was a bit of a gamine out of clothes
young and my mom was an alcoholic
your dad was a gambling addict yeah
briefly in the news a workaholic he's a
lawyer so my mom was a CPA he owns a CPA
firm they both like she owned their own
firms but um and she was into drugs she
was a she was before I was born
I took she had contracted hepatitis C
and then um through birth and then she
also she was a alcoholic like most
[ __ ] yeah very very detached very
not president so how was your childhood
it wasn't wasn't too I can't say it was
like it was to disfranchise but you have
the attention hoping needed and crave
his job did you have siblings
I did but my mom got married to a man
named Dennis first you say names but
well make that married to man he's
really good stuff dad but very very Iron
Fist with him as well
he's a Marine Corps drill instructor so
there's a lot of things that come along
with that yeah and then I got a lot of
sisters out of that 11 some sisters I
five sisters no of course the sisters
and then what do you dream you left home
so when you left your parents Oh 18 I
went to go to college where'd you go I
went to home state
he's briefly you only went there for
about a year that's when I was
introduced to heroin was as young a
winter break from school my older sister
Casey are you still using her
oh yes yeah infant no but predominately
on hold you know I'm 29
what do you do for money now
reacquisition of good bollocks every
appropriation of goods yeah but what do
you spend out heroin
Oh shame from 100 to knows today and all
you are you try not to I do it when I'm
sick or we can't get anything else
what's the difference basically um then
I was a lot more dangerous and nurses it
changes people pretty drastically like
people anyway the deal user Fennell will
will change absolutely corporates to the
personality corporates of their moral
compass will change as well and I've
ever noticed it it's no it's not a
matter of if it's a matter of when
and what kind of changes to you Oh
seeding this fact early people that
weren't she TB come see this is
something of a database that seems like
people that weren't CD become shaving
people that are seeded them seniors
lying stealing playing stealing and like
yeah exactly
yeah and where you say no your intent um
yeah I mean sometimes though you
generally I'm a full round myself a
nomad I turned out I mean I have I have
a mattress pad and I have a seat I have
a blanket
yeah yeah sure do it's police told my
other backpack last night and they job
did that one but yeah and so you find
out your kids I don't I don't but um
yeah yeah thankfully no kids six back to
this but um yeah I did I had a couple
girlfriends and wore anything I she
jumped in front of a train recently um
really your girlfriend jumped on a train
yeah it was weird very broken up but she
was really depressed and she just
recently got on my scooter dad job with
you and she was really depressed and
um I haven't heard from her in a while
but heard something or where did this
happen
the Expo Line I think it was oh yeah
when was that this is the last month
oh yeah so January yeah mr. Christmas
and do you mental issues as well you
think yeah
yeah uh yeah depression spirit
depression um PTSD yeah I was a sexually
assaulted as a youth and and against
I've been out here I'm sorry it is a
youth one was insulted by friends spirit
he said something else happened drug me
I was like staying then I should have
known the signs but I was shining down
my just saying you know what I thought
is this nice dealer you anything else
before we can I get me on the dais and
feed me drugs for free and he drugged me
and then come to and I'd be like what
the [ __ ] is happening and then go back
out and and like three days after that
you know what was going on I was like I
really doesn't irritate me he's like you
knew this was all about from the get-go
I was like I didn't like I wish I did
but I didn't so I hope that was clear
blue yeah yeah yes neighbors its Bess my
dad
yeah brought me here as a kid you know
he drove me around you said this is
where you go every batter I try to avoid
this area as being my home where do you
hang
I do business MacArthur Park but a
logistic towards West Side it's like a
mini scooter over there right exactly
it's like the mini Street Market Skid
Row yeah exactly
no but I say firstly the west side
mostly like it's people seem to be a
little bit kinder out there and you
don't deal with the same [ __ ] as you
do oh yeah yeah right yeah I plan to be
out of here by 7:30 just coming up in
four months yeah so I plan to be off the
street and hopefully clean you get clean
yeah have you been clean before yeah
program just go to they've gone to rehab
I've got bits of sobriety that's what
doesn't discouraged me that was that how
these bits of sobriety then I keep
returning to this this kind of [ __ ]
every times its worst was I've never
been homeless - let's run this one's the
last you were you on medications for
depression nerve yeah everybody knows
that make a difference it's still good
it's true these episodes depression and
you're not taking any no president no
but it wasn't it was it didn't seem to
be helpful at all I was in the hospital
for six weeks here already can tell with
my next pretty messed up
I haven't internal I have an epidural
abscess on my neck at least that's what
he said I have for the six weeks
hospital stay and they know then I said
three days of standing upright again
they didn't always was telling this yeah
is because I have an epidural abscess in
my back because they've returned after
three days of a beam out here he goes
yeah I think one of the other students I
wanted them to go surgically they opted
out of doing that for for the reason he
said it was unsafe
that the the IV antibiotics would
definitely take care of it didn't work
do you still have contact with your
family oh yeah I have a coke my dad my
mom and uh probably a couple months but
call me Dad they know you're out here
yeah yeah they do mr. sir good have you
ever eaten
oh yeah yeah handful times probably if
she went to wrote last relapse need
twice that discovered the sober living I
was saying it yeah
what was the reason for leaking that sir
Berlin was a very super centrality make
sure those those my reason for leaving
that super living it wasn't a very sober
sub religion boys what do you wish was
different about your life for childhood
that might have changed your path I
means people out here that they had so
much worse childrens and I it makes me
kind of grateful really killer the six
that happen to be true but all right
Scott well thank you so much for yeah
and good luck with everything
thank you
you
you